[Musique]
retrouvés à l'espace philippe noiret
cette semaine le dernier film de spike
lee dont je ne me risquerai pas à
prononcer le titre que vous allez voir
sur l'écran donc spike lee revient en
force et en verve avec son dernier film
et il a électrisé la croisette cette
année puisqu'il a obtenu le grand prix
du jury il s'inspire d'une histoire
vraie une histoire incroyable d'un
policier afro américain qui s'est
infiltré dans le klu klux klan donc
voilà c'est un mélange réjouissons de
comédie policière de satire sociale de
pamphlets parce que c'est une charge
aussi très ouverte contre l'amérique de
trump con que l'actuel président
américain voilà en résumé un film
d'action militante pour ne pas bouder
notre plaisir à retrouver dans notre
salle à l'espace philippe noiret cette
semaine n'ont eu que peu kukoc sauce
[Musique]